Coffee it's not you it's me
coffee we've had some great times but I
just think we need to see other people
for a little while so I drink a lot of
coffee every day I drink about two to
three cups of coffee depending on my
mood and my grounding s I think I just
like having a cup of coffee in my hand I
like having something to do I don't like
sitting at my desk for too long because
it makes me go crazy for me to feel wake
throughout a workday it used to be three
or four cups of coffee and it was five
or six cups of coffee now it's six to
eight cups of coffee and with that
increase of caffeine I think I'm
starting to develop anxiety I'm
interested in cutting out coffee because
I have anxiety and coffee definitely
doesn't help that taking a step back and
thinking you know if you're really
anxious maybe the cups of stimulants
you're pouring into your mouth
throughout the day is a thing to check
in on can caffeine cause anxiety yes so
caffeine can exacerbate anxiety that
already exists but caffeine can also
independently cause anxiety that's kind
of why I'm doing this I'm trying to just
quit cold turkey and I'm not gonna have
a drink of caffeine or anything else
that has caffeine in it for seven days
to see if I can get this out of my
system so it's gonna be a brutal first
couple of days tomorrow is gonna be a
nightmare what symptoms can we expect by
cutting out caffeine 50% of the time
people will experience a headache when
they quit using caffeine cold-turkey its
fatigue or sleepiness you know just
being more tired than usual be very
sleepy yawning difficulty concentrating
being depressed irritable and also in
certain cases people experience a
fluid-like syndrome so
as a replacement of coffee today I
figure I'm just going to do water
stay hydrated I assumed being hydrated
easy energy I just woke up it's day 1
and I have so much to do today I'm I
think today's gonna be a struggle so day
one without coffee and I'm already
craving it real hard so I think I'm
gonna get a giant bottle of water to
hydrate and hopefully that will get rid
of my craving day one was surprisingly
not too intense it felt like the calm
before the storm almost because I've had
caffeine headaches and withdrawal before
but my first day not drinking coffee I
didn't have any headaches or anything
but I felt like something was a little
off somatic or what feel like I can just
fall asleep standing up by now my
trainers super delayed and I'm already
kinda grumpy so I'm gonna try to find
something to hold me over
I'm caffeinated I don't know how this is
gonna turn out day one I didn't do
anything to replace coffee and I think
that was my biggest problem I just had a
seltzer and that didn't do anything for
me the whole day was a haze I felt like
a zombie going through I would describe
the first day really is just tired it's
not quite coffee
I was just sleepy I didn't feel any sort
of withdrawal from the coffee I didn't
feel sick I don't think I was irritable
this stuff does jack-shit that entire
day at work I really got very little
accomplished because I couldn't I
couldn't stay focused I didn't feel like
I was bringing anything or any energy to
do my work work now I didn't end up
getting a little bit of a headache
and I was like falling asleep standing
up
it's not even 8:30 and it feels like
it's midnight the headache is spread in
my whole forehead it feels like
somebody's just pushing in on the sides
of my head constantly caffeine is a is a
drug that directly antagonizes a certain
receptor in the brain called the
adenosine and adenosine is a substance
in the brain that sort of makes us
sleepy
your body is accustom let's say but
seven or eight cups of coffee a day to
having so much antagonism of adenosine
and then what happens is when you would
properly remove it now you have all this
extra adenosine because the body always
compensates and so when you remove the
caffeine now you have more adenosine
binding then you would be accustomed to
which makes you sleepy and tired and can
also cause that throbbing sensitive to
movement headache there's a video that
my girlfriend shot of me I just passed
out on the couch while we were watching
television and in the video you see like
I am in the most uncomfortable position
in the next morning I still woke up and
I was tired
usually caffeine withdrawal Peaks
between about 20 hours after your last
dose and about 60 hours after your last
dose so sometime in the first two to
three days is when people will
experience the worst symptoms the second
day is lying noticed the withdrawal a -
walking to work and it's raining and I
have headaches now day two I start to
actually feel the physical symptoms and
that was a
probably the hardest day I had every
intention to go to the gym today because
I felt like the hotel me wake up still
feel so tired I got my ass shot a bed at
6:00 a.m. somehow and I'm headed for a
short workout my energy got completely
kick-started when I went to the gym and
I felt really really good better than if
I had a cup of coffee in the morning I'm
hoping today goes a lot better than
yesterday I'm feeling a little bit more
confident about the challenge I think
it's gonna get better so I think that
was definitely the key and I tried to
stick with that throughout the whole
seven days and I've noticed the days
that I do go to the gym I feel a lot
better in the morning I also noticed how
many people on the subways are on the
streets are holding coffee how many
coffee shops there are in New York City
you can't walk a block without passing
three or four of them the weekend became
difficult I went upstate to Tarrytown
with my girlfriend we just wanted a nice
day out inside the city and so every
corner there are coffee shops and the
smell of coffee just like what like
wafting through the air I knew that that
was gonna become the worst day I think
this is a sign and I felt bad for my
girlfriend who was really enjoying that
day that I really wasn't present because
I was just so tired so on day three I
cracked on day three I I realized this
is not something I'm able to do cold
turkey this is just one this is just
that's the weekend I'm very tired as
soon as I tasted that the coffee on my
tongue my body started like getting
ready for it
like I already psych might the colours
started getting a little bit more
vibrant the world started getting a
little clear I would drink coffee for
the rest of the experiment but I would
do it just one cup of coffee in the
morning and at no point throughout the
rest of the day would I allow myself to
have more caffeine I could have one
drink and that was going to be it go
from eight to one weekend was tough I
was at brunch and everyone I was with
started taunting me with their coffees
just like like looking at me in the eyes
and drinking it or like just like
shoving it and like my face so I need to
get new friends for sure hello hello
it's the end of day four and I made it
through wonderfully I actually didn't
have any headaches at all today I think
working out has been the key to keeping
my energy elevated without caffeine so I
cheated a little bit and I went to a
vitamin store around the block from work
and the oath mate suggested was ginseng
and apparently that will uh I won't give
me energy without giving me caffeine I
feel like it was a future right now I'd
like everyone else's in 2017 I'm in 30
17 taking energy pills with ginseng
as I was taking a nice thoughts is not
free on the side and that actually did
make me feel pretty level-headed and
energized and I got a lot of work done
so I don't know it could have just been
a placebo who knows it definitely feels
miles away from where I was last week
for sure
I did notice a really big difference I
noticed the anxiety was gone
I don't think cutting out caffeine
benefited my mental health the time I've
also been very productive at work
working out helped it that definitely
like sued the anxiety I do remember the
day that we did the first interview I
was way more I was just thinking about
how anxious I was right now there's no
part of my brain that I'm thinking like
man my anxiety is out of control today
one thing that many people don't realize
is that when you become tolerant to a
drug you don't become tolerant to all
the effects in the same way at the same
time so what often happens is people
become tolerant to the stimulating
effects of the drug let's say or the the
euphoric effects of the drug but they
don't become tolerant to some of the
side effects of a drug and so going
forward I'm gonna drink one cup of
coffee every day yay really it's up to
me if I want to drink it this is a test
I'm not gonna drink this coffee and I'm
not ready to like I'm not ready to give
in yet and I'm considering trying to cut
out coffee for longer I think I'm not
ready to get back into coffee I think
I'm gonna get back into it but I think I
might wait til til maybe tomorrow so I
will not be drinking this cup of coffee
because I already drank my coffee today
and and this would be completely
unnecessary
based on your experience a it's like can
you think this but